what's up with sean penn where has he
been lately has his lack of time in
hollywood had to do with kobe 19 or his
humanitarian work keep watching to find
out
one of the things that may have kept
sean penn from pursuing more film and tv
work in the past few years is likely the
time and effort he put into writing and
promoting his novel bob honey who just
do stuff published by simon schuster's
atria books in 2018 bob honey tells the
story of a supposed international
assassin with a penchant for pummeling
his elderly targets with a mallet this
story is told from the point of view of
papi pariah a character who pen
initially claimed to be the true author
of the book the following year penn put
out a sequel bob honey sings jimmy crack
corn during his promotion of the first
book penn had indicated that he could
give up acting to become a full-time
novelist he told vogue at the time i
have a much better time writing books
that'll probably dominate my creative
energies for the foreseeable future
whether or not that's a journey that
readers will be willing to join him on
remains to be seen however his debut
novel was widely panned by critics with
mark hill of cracked calling it the
worst novel in human history and the
literary equivalent of renal failure
ouch i'm 57 my pool's heated you can say
anything you like
long before he penned his debut novel
penn was incredibly involved in his work
outside of acting for decades he has
maintained an active role in a number of
humanitarian efforts and social justice
projects penn was notably involved in
aiding victims of hurricane katrina in
2005 and was likewise on the scene in
haiti following the catastrophic
earthquake that rocked the island nation
in 2010. these are but a few of the
initiatives he has spearheaded or been
involved with over the years this is not
political this is the most unpolitical
thing there is amid the kovan 19
pandemic the non-profit he co-founded in
the wake of the haiti disaster core has
been working diligently to curb the
spread of the novel coronavirus there as
well as in the us the group's efforts
have included providing free tests and
working with local governments on
getting more people vaccinated core had
been coordinating with the haitian
government on a massive vaccination
program before the murder of president
javel muiz in july penn told washington
post live an initial 1.5 million
vaccines was committed we were getting
ready to rock and roll and then that
horrible assassination happened penn's
core partner and lee added that the
group nonetheless has 25 vaccination
locations in operation with plans to
expand in the future the group is also
assisting in the recovery from the
latest earthquake in this instance this
was more of a no-brainer to say hey
how can we help when it comes to
questions of where has sean penn been in
the era of covid19 well there's usually
one big reason involved and speaking of
the pandemic pen has been outspoken on
the importance of doing all we can to
prevent the spread of the disease he is
taking time to care for his own health
that of his hollywood peers and also for
the good of humankind the issue is so
important to him in fact that he has
sacrificed acting work and ongoing
projects in response to the crisis as
reported by deadline earlier this summer
penn has refused to continue his work on
gaslit until every member of the show's
cast and crew has been vaccinated in an
effort to make that happen penn has
reportedly offered to facilitate the
vaccination effort free of charge
through core penn told usa today
recently i think it should be as
mandatory as turning on your headlights
on a car at night i will go back to work
on gaslit when it has been confirmed to
me that the entire crew top to bottom
will be vaccinated he further admonished
moviegoers to get vaccinated before
heading to theaters to check out flag
day but most of the people who aren't
vaccinated probably aren't interested in
my movies yeah that's a good point
penn is being pulled in a number of
different directions and also has clear
concerns about kovan 19 however another
major factor in his decision to take on
fewer acting rules may be that he just
doesn't have the love for the discipline
that he once did he famously alluded to
this during a 2018 interview with tracy
smith for cbs sunday morning saying it
can be great when you're working with
good actors or good directors or good
writing is an exercise but do i have a
belief that it has a lasting value maybe
i could make the argument intellectually
but i don't have a visceral i'm not in
love with that anymore despite having
made proclamations like this penn has
obviously continued to act albeit not
often as the frequency with which he has
shown up in new projects has slowed
considerably since his heyday
penn has thrilled audiences in a
veritable bonanza of roles over his
decades on the big screen however his
most iconic performance may still be his
1982 turn as jeff spicoli and amy
heckerling's coming of age classic fast
times at ridgemont high in the film penn
established the gold standard of high
school stoner characters his battle of
wits with a cantankerous old history
teacher called mr hand is unforgettable
whilst piccoli may be frozen in time and
in the minds of movie fans around the
world penn himself is a high schooler no
longer the man behind the myth is now in
his 60s for reference ray walton who
played mr hand was also a sexy
generation when he filmed fast times
giving his advancing age as well as the
reality that he is technically in his
fifth decade in hollywood penn may just
have done and accomplished everything he
wanted to do as an actor check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]